all right history now what's a time all
right quadratic equations talked a
little bit about Babylonians I didn't
write the Chinese because when I was
typing this up last night I couldn't
find information to confirm what I
thought on you but I'm pretty sure the
Chinese at the right moment in history
you know about completing the square and
as I love saying to my students if the
ancient Babylonians could complete the
square why can't you
Euclid that was a surprise to me when I
read it I didn't know that you put was
involved in quadratic equations and I
could be wrong but it's interesting okay
who had it hands it's Brahmagupta quite
a well-known Indian mathematician we're
in AD now he was the first to be quite
rigorous about quadratic equations
alright in the historical context all of
the ancients they they didn't have
equations they had problems right you
know you take this area of land and you
do this and you do that and you end up
with this result and what what did you
start with or something like that and
they didn't have algebra they had
processes that they described by pitting
them so but even Brahma Gupta he did
describe the solution you know somewhat
algebraic way it was just a paragraph of
text instead of a formula and he he
celebrated or used negative numbers it
just didn't catch on in Europe until
much much much much much later this
mathematician joinder of Abraham here is
he
liebe in Medora was published in
European 1145 which like really
seriously dealt with the quadratic kind
of once and for all
okay not in modern algebraic notation of
course but yeah I couldn't tell you what
the difference between those two I mean
maybe it's just a case of taking
knowledge a while to spread maybe it's
some refinement maybe is maybe it's a
more thorough treatment of the different
kinds of quadratic equations maybe it's
talk of a discriminant who knows you
think the presenter would alright now we
get to sixteenth century Italy and this
is amazing right this is the bang bang
bang bang in the one century in the one
place del Ferro and by a who's head of
Cardona okay so we look less than half
the room right Kodama is a giant of the
story but del Ferro solved the depressed
cubic now we've seen both which one do
you think was hard the depressed cubic
or the general cubic the depressed cubic
is the correct answer
alright that was hard getting from the
the getting from the general cubic to
the depressed cubic it was not that hard
the substitution wasn't their heart the
simplification and all that was not that
hard it didn't it required that the
insight tonight is that one substitution
but the depressed cubic one that
involved all sorts of ports in the road
and needing some really some genius some
inspiration now I I understand that he
did it in a different way but the way he
did it looks equally impressive and once
again they didn't have algebraic
notation so that right you know he got
four plus n dot four minus capital R
with a subscript X for route radix
and yeah so cardano's well-known and his
slide is very long but this guy should
be well known so super needle furrow he
was a lecturer in arithmetic and
geometry at the University of Bologna
despite it amazing that there were
universities but there wasn't in Italy
at the time so you know the seems like
the principal social organization in
this world isn't nation-states its
universities so he solved the depressed
cubic in 1515 and it's very interesting
if you're not already aware of this
which I wasn't until I read that book
even though he was at university and a
lecturer there was not a culture of
publishing your results and sharing in
knowledge
bit different from nowadays certainly no
publish or perish back then he kept that
to himself
and there's a very good reason he kept
it to himself the way you've got ahead
in those days was largely by
competitions at any time someone with
enough skill and enough cheek could
challenge him effectively for his job so
I challenge you to a public competition
I'm gonna write 30 maths problems for
you to solve
you write 30 for me to solve see who
wins
there were audiences yeah and so he came
that knowledge to himself so that he
could defend any potential challenge now
I don't know any data on how many
challenges he faced in his life but that
was the culture of the of the time and
that runs through our story
okay two big players Fiore was Fiore was
del Pharaohs student Delano they was del
Feroz Sonny more and when del Ferrara
was dying in 1526 he passed on his
knowledge of this cubic to these two
gentlemen they didn't broadcast it they
didn't need it as much as he did
although the students started to get
ambition till now they son in war I
don't know if he had anything to do with
mathematics so he just he actually kept
the Pharaohs notebooks which is
important for them later in the story so
these guys kept his secret but they
weren't completely tight-lipped
you know word got around that that
either word got around that the
depressed cubic has been solved or at
least at some progressing cubic
equations that they made yes I never
thought about that that's a yeah
although it never ceases to amaze me how
much biographical information is known
about these people and so you hope to
think that if if other people did make
that kind of progress and it would have
be found out eventually
yeah yeah that's right and another
player later in this story some of his
books were found in a university library
in 1925 yeah I hadn't thought about
that's a good point
so um so it was it was kept secret so
yeah Dylan are they kept the books Fiore
just kept their knowledge
okay Tattaglia now Mary you mentioned
tartar yesterday and said now what do we
know about tart earlier and I shut you
down pretty quickly as now I was
actually attempting to shut you down but
that got me wondering well I'm not gonna
say that many things about to tell you
so what were you going to say about so
to tell you I was in his ninth Niccolo
Fontana which is now known as Tertullian
stammerer rings a bell we've probably
read the same Wikipedia page his
achievements where he solved this a
cubic of this form 1535 so 20 years and
I think just like when the four-minute
mile was broken and then other people
did write the knowledge that something
can be done the inspires people to do it
and so I think the word getting around
that progress was being made and
inspired people both by knowing it could
be done and secondly by needing to build
up some resources for a competition
perhaps okay so he solved this one and
then there's a wonderful story about how
we came to solve this one all right now
this is a rediscovery because that's the
same as del carro Fiore the student
challenged Italia
a competition Tattaglia was he had a
good teaching position I think it was in
Venice for your I wanted it if you're a
had this secret there was perhaps a
sense that things were moving on the
cubic front and so Fiore thought well
I've got this knowledge that won't be
secret forever I'd better use it
challenge to a competition Tattaglia um
the night before the competition totally
rediscovered it's so heavy or a had no
competitive advantage whatsoever and
figure I didn't have this one and he got
wiped clean
in the competition alright so Dahlia was
supreme there I for all the reading I've
done on this I have not seen how that
was soft and probably the reason for
that is it's not important to the story
we saw have a general one led to the to
this one right we don't need a specific
solution to that but I'd be interested
to see the method